A WeakSet is just like a set,
except there are a number of
limitations, or I guess you
could say benefits to using a
WeakSet in some situations.
We create it just like we would
before, and you can pass it an
iterable of items, so dog1 and
dog2. I could also have done
WeakSauce.add dog2. Let's check
it out, WeakSauce, there we go.
I can say .hasDog1, that is true, .
hasDog2. The important thing
that we need to know here about
a WeakSet is that a WeakSet can
only ever contain objects. It
cannot contain strings, or
numbers, or arrays, or anything
else. It can only ever contain
an object. Now, we'll see why
that's important in just a
second. That's one thing that we
need to know about it. The
other thing we need to know
about it is you cannot
ennumerate, or you cannot loop
over it, so we couldn't do our
for constDog of WeakSauce and
then console.log dog. Watch the
error that it gives us, symbol.
iterator is not a function.
There is no iterator on a
WeakSet like there is on an
array, or on a set, or any of
the other things that we can use
a for of on, so that's out the
window. You might be thinking, "
Well, that's kind of weak. Why
would I ever want to use that?"
Really, the last thing that we
need to know about a WeakSet is
that there is no .clear method.
If I have my WeakSauce here,
there is no .clear method that I
can call against it, and I'll
tell you why. Because the
WeakSets sort of clean
themselves up. This has
everything to do with garbage
collection and memory. What that
means is that when the reference
to one of these dogs no longer
exists, for example, if we were
to delete one of these dogs,
then it would automatically be
garbage collected, which means
it would automatically be taken
out of our WeakSet. We have
the set that is weakly held,
which means that things can just
automatically go away because if
they're deleted in the code that
you're running, then they are
going to be also deleted from
the set. To demonstrate that,
what I'm going to do is set dog1
to be null, and I'm just going
to console.log the WeakSet right
here. When does garbage
collection happen? It really
depends on your browser and a
whole bunch of other things.
There's no way to force it. But
generally what you can do is you
can wait for a couple seconds
and you'll see that the WeakSet
has been gone. We're going
to conole.log the WeakSet here,
and then I'm going to console.
log WeakSet here. We'll see if
that does anything. Not the
WeakSet, the WeakSauce. Poor
name. Here we deleted dog1,
but it's still in here. Does
that mean we still have...That's
what's called a memory leak to
some people, where you reference
something that cannot be a
reference otherwise. I've
just waited here a couple
seconds now, and let's type it
in, WeakSauce. Now it's gone.
You see how Snickers is no
longer in there? It's because we
deleted it in our JavaScript,
and the WeakSet ran a garbage
collection that says, "OK, who
of my items no longer exists?
Because get out of here, we
don't need you any longer.
You've been garbage collected."
Not a whole bunch of use cases
for that, but if you're storing
like a DOM node or any type of
other object, then you don't
have to make sure that...Even
though you delete the actual
reference to the object, you
don't have to worry about it
also being in an array or
something somewhere and causing
a memory leak. You'll know that
the WeakSet is going to take
care of it for you.